uh i grew up in a family where it was
trash airport novels like my
and my parents would trade back and
forth and so like i grew up reading
um and not all of this is bad but i mean
i i definitely grew up reading
like heinlein and uh robert ledlum
and stuff like that like from a very
very early age so when like the bourne
movies came out i was like that's not
robert ludlum i was like
i knew it like you know 16 years old or
whatever i was like that's not right
um but i i i've always kind of um
i've had a fascination with reading for
sure
but as of late it's been like pretty
pretty highbrow more philosophy uh
and so i'm going back and forth and and
i i started reading marcus aurelius and
that led to like
um epictetus and that led to seneca and
then
i someone talked to me about alan watts
i was like never read him so i'm gonna
check it out
and so i started reading alan watts and
then alan watts has now led to aldous
huxley
uh because apparently those guys used to
[ __ ] trip together so
uh what kind of philosophy are you
reading
uh it's really cool i'm doing east meets
west so it's like
seneca and the stoics and the cynics
from like greek philosophy and these are
roman people it's interesting because
there's these roman dudes that are
looking back to greece going they had it
all figured out
um and then it was a whole cultural
movement
yeah which is interesting because like
marcus
and seneca and all these cats wrote
their
i mean the stoic like marcus never meant
for his [ __ ] to be read by anybody he
was just doing it to his
to himself and probably because seneca
died he was a trainer or teacher of his
so he's continuing the conversation in
notes but they all
wrote these in greek not roman
because they figured they they
considered it more of a higher learning
thing and so
um it's really kind of cool but the alan
watts of it comes in because
that dude's kind of responsible for like
that's why we have richard gere
because like he modernized and
introduced buddhism to
to the west and specifically america so
like alan watts and he's kind of like
the
the preeminent dude when it comes to zen
um but they all there was this place
that they used to hang out in
uh in beverly hills actually it's
it's still there it's a small unassuming
place uh that like watts would hang out
at and aldous huxley and all these guys
so i mean it's like and and all this
huxley died in like 63 so i mean he was
he was pretty old when he was getting
into this [ __ ] but i was gonna say i
i did not know they ever had any
interactions because i
think of aldous huxley as significantly
earlier than alan watts but i'm not an
expert on either so it struck me as like
huxley was really yeah from what i
understand huxley was coming up in like
the 40s and 50s but he was kind of like
on the outs
as alan watts was like starting to tune
in because like
watts wrote the way of zen in the 60s so
have you
played or checked out any of you um the
game everything
no what is this yes yeah of course you
have mike
it's narrated they actually used audio
clips right yeah exactly the game has
alan watts uh speeches interspersed
throughout like his actual voice
speaking i love that
those
yeah the idea of the game is it's like
it's like this exploration through the
universe at every scale so you can you
can like
you can explore yeah
that's like the equivalent of austin not
knowing who the composer was
mike not having the book behind him i've
never played that game before
i mean in alana's defense she does play
all the games
all of the games although i love that
the the idea that this one would
because it's like it doesn't have that
much competition it's like if i asked
you
you know did you play that one shooter i
could see they're being uh maybe i don't
know but it's like did you play the one
alan watts sort of zen
[Music]
knowing the the publisher in the studio
that did this
i'm i'm gonna pretty much assume that
these guys were
uh were doing some drugs when they made
this game
um i do wonder about that a lot of the
time i have a running theory that um
much less philosophical thing to say
that uh the writers of spongebob were
just always high
otherwise i don't know how that show
gets made oh dude
for real i i think that's pretty
much less cool but spongebob
bond drugs are you familiar with those
characters
are you familiar with sound self no
by uh robin are not um now that
now robin was definitely hiding yes
robin what is it what are you talking
about what's it called uh it's called
sound self as one word not not only
was robin definitely on something but
the whole point of the game
is to give the user a
a simulation of that like specifically
like
psychedelics this just came out it did
yeah but it's been in development like i
i robin's a friend and i yeah i think i
contributed to the kickstarter like six
years ago or something
all right so every child of eden more
than any game i've ever played
made me think maybe i'll do drugs one
day
here's what's so funny is i i love the
dispassionate like
i will consider that i'll put it on the
list of maybes still haven't
but if i would i would play child of
eating
okay so but without without
incriminating anybody like so i i was
vehemently against anything i smoked two
packs a day at one time
and would drink like a fish but i i drew
the line
at whatever especially in texas growing
up what was considered
legal so like pot any of that never
never did that so um i it wasn't until i
lived here for the longest time and it
was my 34th
birthday i think it was that sounds
about right
um uh travis willingham came to me was
like all right dude
we're gonna get you high i was like oh
no and i love how this started without
incriminating anybody and then
you know myself
absolutely yeah it was legal at the time
um it was still the prescription thing
and so
uh i had my first like doctor experience
doctor travis
um a bunch of brownies tonight
um and so like that that was and i
realized i was like okay i
now i understand this i was fearing the
unknown and i now understand what this
is
and then i went to this like time period
for a while where whereas like it became
my bourbon it became like you it's super
uber pretentious especially in la
because you go to the dispensary
and everyone's like well this right here
is 40 this it's you know and they can
trace back the lineage it's like
racehorses it's
it's weird um and so i took it yeah
integrity i do would take integrity um
i so i went a little too far over uh and
then i and then i rained it back and
it's kind of like whatever now
but i've never done any psychedelic and
i've never
that that to me is kind of like again
another hard line um
where i just i don't think i would want
to
even though it's expanding your
consciousness i just don't think that i
would allow my i have a real issue with
especially physically being out of
control i i i never got to the point
where i get blackout drunk
even getting high i was like i want to
be able to like just have a little bit
of a buzz i don't want to be like super
trippy balls hi
um so i don't i don't think i could ever
do like
obviously this book is talking about
specifically mescaline and how
that expanded aldous huxley and all
these guys their consciousness and stuff
and i was like
i'll read about it so i want to see that
at least academically i can understand
it
and i would love to play a game that
like
focused on that and and to somehow
represent um and in the same way like
the case of the curious dog at midnight
or whatever was done
as a here's what it's like to be uh
on the spectrum um uh it's it's
completely told from the perspective of
a kid who's autistic and it's abu i was
like
holy [ __ ] i now understand like my
nephew i understand so much more about
the world
as he experiences it um so maybe that's
the same thing i don't know
super weird way to start our podcast but
there you go
[Laughter]
psychedelic edition oh my god i'm alana
and i'm joined by
composer austin wintery uh video game
actor troy baker
and video game director mike bethel um
you know i feel like starting off with
talking about drugs is i can segue into
our topic here somehow
uh drugs apparently sometimes really
take things to the next level
just like next gen gaming all right wow
wow i do want to say before this goes up
there is a ghost of tsushima um
presentation that's going to go up today
at some point in time so we will not
have
it's like yeah it's like two hours dying
to see more of that game
i think too man i'm just because i don't
feel i've got a handle on what it is yet
i want to see
i've seen really it looks well just it
looks beautiful but i just i've not
quite
i've not got a map in my head of the
design yet you know i think when you see
games you're like i like the aesthetic
but i don't know what it is
yeah like i don't know what the menus
are in the game is
it definitely feels like something i
need to play to understand yeah but not
like on a death stranding level like
that's what i was going to say
it reminds me of the initiation there
where i was going i don't
have any clue what this game will
actually be well i think
what we've seen ago sushima has been
game play whereas death stranding it was
largely cinematic oh yeah
oh there's no like there's nothing yeah
there's no accusation on my path like
it's i don't know
does this change gameplay whatever this
is going to age really badly hopefully
we'll know in
two hours the audience knows more than
we do right now yeah
i think that just by and large like that
studio look at what sucker punch has
done
and they they did one thing really
really well and the
one thing that i can um really commend
them for
is from the top down from brian on down
those guys are not a studio to rest on
their laurels and they like
really really push themselves and to go
we have a hit franchise
[ __ ] it let's shake it up and they
reboot their own franchise and then they
go all right there's a good franchise
we don't want to do that anymore because
we haven't worked on the same thing for
the last 10 years how can we really
stretch the studio
and iterate iterate iterate iterate on
their ideas
like a lot y'all like they they they
went through demo after demo after demo
to land on this
and i really really commend those guys
billy harper especially
um is just an amazing talent
um i can't say enough nice stuff about
that guy that guy is
he did almost all the move sets for
delson
uh himself on a trampoline and a move on
suit and he's just
he's [ __ ] awesome i loved infamous i
loved i loved them at the
second song in the what was the dlc
called oh dude first light
laura bailey amazing laura bailey's just
like
it frustrates me how
how just completely effortlessly good
she is
and just drops into any role that she is
she can play a badass in gears
she can play punk in first lighter or
second son
um can she play a
lead in a musical that's the question
that's the real question
that's the real question is that the is
that the like is that the measure is it
yeah dude she's she i will say this
laura went from laura's got an
incredible voice
and she is very timid and very reserved
about it
um and she finally was really super
brave
and put a thing up on instagram of just
her singing this sara bareilles song
on a piano that i bought her for her
birthday and
she crushed it i was like and it just
exploded and people
just showered her with love and i think
it gave her a lot of confidence so when
we cast her in chorus
i was like she did so very very
trepidatiously because she's like holy
[ __ ] now
again kind of like sucker punch it's
like i'm not gonna rest on my laurels
i'm actually gonna step out and be brave
and do something that really makes me
tremble
and she's crushing it like she came in
and she sings from such
she sings from the same place she acts
from it's just incredibly
it was cool watching the two of you work
when we were doing the prototype because
troy
for those unaware troy was uh directing
and so much of it was basically just
about giving her
the freedom to not be timid essentially
just like creating that space
of like you got this you don't actually
need me i'm not a vocal coach in this
instance i'm not i'm not even
directing in the traditional sense i
mean i know i'm kind of putting words in
your mouth but that's what it really
looked like from my
pov because it was like she would sing
the song
or sing that fragment um
you know technically accurately and then
you'd be like okay
cool so now like perform it
essentially obviously you said it more
effectively than that but then it was
like the next take i remember you
turning to me and it was like
holy [ __ ] that just exploded to the next
level and all it took was just that like
letting go of that
that last lingering kind of self-doubt
you know
just real quick get one of you to
explain what chorus is for people who
yes uh austin go for it you'll tease
chorus
is a a video game musical
currently in progress possibly
uh in a curious
uh situation regarding its name yeah
but uh i didn't know if you were gonna
go there but yeah well i mean it's just
like oh no no yeah it's an unknown at
this point
oh really i didn't know that and uh well
i i
i mean it's an unknown if only for me
what the outcome uh will be there if um
if someone's gonna have to change names
if it won't matter
i don't know i don't because i don't
know what's legal i don't know what's
best practice
because i know in music for example you
can't copyright a title that's why
there's a thousand songs called you know
the sunset or whatever like
right titles are not copyrightable in
music but in games i think it might be
different and i
don't know well trademarks in particular
would be different yeah
yeah register yeah bottom line it's a
game that we're developing with
summerfall studios
uh that was originally part of a fig go
fig campaign that that got funded
super super fast uh and it's a
completely interactive
uh musical um and laura is our
is our lead and the the thing about
laura
i love that this has become a laura
bailey episode um
she is fantastic for anyone who hasn't
heard she's phenomenally good
anyone who hasn't played gs5 honestly
that performance is
just insane just insane it's so
good like she and she was a huge this is
the what gives her the edge
is that laura's a gamer and she goes
into that
uh with an incredible knowledge of the
franchise that she's playing
uh or in the the franchise that she is
going to play right
so she went into gears going i know
exactly what this is um
in the same way a lot of that you did as
well um
i i feel like the true star of gears 5.
yeah laura bailey laura comes from
a she she's she's a a swiss army knife
because she comes from a theater
background
so she has that inherent uh respect for
the text
inherent respect for um the director and
and
all of the people that have gone into
the page
that she's being presented with so she
honors the page in every aspect not just
the words but everything that comes to
that um and and her thing is being able
to
move within those confines what's what's
fun about her
is the first directing big directing job
that i had
uh was on shadow of war and she was cast
as altaria um even though she'd also
been
she had played previously in the first
game my wife um
they're they're just kind of hand-waved
they're like yeah it's the same person
it doesn't matter
um it's kind of like what david milch
did on deadwood uh
so she comes in and i was like i'm super
nervous
i feel super uh um apprehensive about
you know sometimes we're like working
with friends and directing friends
specifically
but i thought okay laura's going to be
here it's going to be easy peasy and she
ended up being one of the most
challenging ones
and there was one scene in particular
that we had where
both of us were frustrated and i i
pulled her off to the side i was like
dude what the [ __ ]
what is going on it's like you're you're
like get off my dick like what what is
wrong with you
and she was like don't ask me how i feel
that's
my business i want you as the director
to tell me
where i need to start and where i need
to end and trust me enough to know that
i'll be able to get there
and let me figure that out and she was
absolutely right because i was trying to
direct her
in one narrow way walk up to an actor
and ask them how they're feeling what
are they thinking if that's not what
they want to do they're like yo that's
my secret and i'm going to i'm going to
let you
know that through my process and i'll
let you know that through my performance
i'm not just going to tell you that
because now it's cheap now it's out
there now we all know what i'm doing
there's no subtext i was like
get yours girl and she crushed it and
that's when the scene turned and it
became like that's what it was
i was actually the one that's the
director that was holding that scene
back
and she was the one that allowed me to
to send it to new heights so
she is and she's also been a director
so she has worked on both sides of the
glass
and a lot of times exactly what you're
saying austin
she just needs to be reminded it's like
yo you have
fun to play with this and and and truly
make this your own and she just needs to
be given permission sometimes but
yeah so she's awesome there you go laura
bailey there's your there's your
exhaustive plug if anyone ever contested
that i would i would question who they
are as a person they're like laura
bailey not that good i'd be like
yeah just kind of garden variety
overrated overrated
who are you she won't tell you what
she's feeling she won't tell you what
she's feeling i don't know
i always wonder though related to uh uh
mortal
how that nemesis system just didn't end
up in every game
i thought it was so fantastic and it
could have been in mad max it's wb
and it would have worked really well for
mad max and i i expected when that came
out for
everyone to try to copy it and when it
didn't end up in every video game i was
like why
mad max was was in development before
shadow of war yeah so and that was
avalanche
came out after but it was in development
before um
well so shadow shadow of mortar went
through like multiple iterations
the the team changed the whole story
changed my character changed
i was originally i came in the original
name of the character was bad
you were a batman the original the
character was batman
um and it so that that was that was a
really really rough time i think for gay
i feel like i'm dominating but
it was a really rough time for games
because everyone was like are we going
to be launch title are we not are we
going to be legacy are we going to be
and so everyone was kind of doing this
weird dance uh and then
shadow of order ended up going from
being a legacy title to kind of a launch
title
um and it was the first
game that was really capable of like
look under the hood and see what this
thing can do
um but i don't know i i feel like a lot
of people were like yo we don't
we're not gonna do a cover of that song
like you guys did that really really
well
and we're not going to just blatantly
steal that tech first of all it's their
attack right it's it's it's
built based upon their engine um but
they're not just going to be very
difficult to implement like that was a
thing where when that game came out i
was like give it maybe three years and
everyone will have their own nemesis
system because that's
that i feel like that wasn't easy to
make it's very complicated no
but i think conceptually though i think
there's been some aspects
of that right mike don't you think that
there's been some aspects of a nemesis
system and
emerging
system is gamepl very easy to do the
genius of it is coming up with the idea
and the design and the
and making a project around it the
actual carlos said a solo it's super
either a picasso painting you like then
go i could have done that but you didn't
do it first exactly and that's what and
so i was in the alana camp i was
basically saying like
now that now that we all have this idea
out in the open
we this would theoretically come up but
i think i think troy's 100 right i think
it
i think it informed a lot of designers
but obviously no one wanted to be the
people who just copied it
so i think there's a lot of stuff you
look at like the way ubisoft's open
world structure shifted
i think there's a lot of stuff that that
took from that in terms of
uh the assassin's creed games have
definitely stolen some stuff from the
nemesis system the
far cry games in terms of how those
outposts work there's there's kind of
some nice tangential things i think the
i was going to say yeah i think that's i
think that's shifted honestly yeah
obviously literally i think it has a
nemesis
system with these bounty hunters uh
that's right
that's right as well i don't remember
i'm like i think they might
be but i think that's what they did is
they i think a lot of people very
kind of skillfully took those design
lessons which which was basically that
you can have
so you would say that that system was
not difficult
to program oh the first time i'm sure it
cost
millions of dollars and lots of time
because i met because you because the
problem when you're making something
it's that classic thing of like why do
people clone games the the hot people
think that the making of the game is the
hard bit the making of the game
if you know the game you're making it
doesn't take very long to make a game on
on like uh
on on like a well look at thomas was
alone is your is the quintessential
example right right that game took three
years but if i made it tomorrow
no but did you say like the prototype
was like three days though
that was like yeah sure that's the thing
is
it's not a technical challenge so a good
example of this is i've been playing
around with
like a little and a future project or
like a micro i saw your tweet
i want to know what that is i will one
once we've all switched our mics off i
will absolutely tell you
but it's um but because that's actually
set uh based on something so there's a
lot of rules kind of already established
the prototype of that took like a couple
of days a couple of days to make because
the thinking is the hard bit
and then of course art production and
all of that stuff and code obviously
like
i'm not saying games are easy to make
but like i think people overestimate how
hard it's much easier to make the second
game it's a clone if you
that's why mobile game makers will spend
like two years making threes
and then any coder that's half decent
can make a clone of threes in a weekend
that doesn't mean that those guys who
made the first one were slow it just
means they were figuring it out they
were making a million wrong choices and
coming back to him working out so yeah
with something like the nemesis system
yes for a triple a studio making an open
world game it would be
very financially achievable to
just add that into their game if they
came if they had it from the conceptual
face that's the other thing is as well
like if you think about how long a
big aaa game is in development for um
you know it does they would have to
decide on this right at the start
because
one thing with the nemesis system is
it's a hierarchical structural thing
where
if you're on you couldn't add it into a
game you'd already made you'd have to
have it right from day one it is very
all that game's core
really yeah well you have to tear down
the game you're making
which is from what troy's saying sounds
like that's kind of what they did they
kind of had to
dig it out and build it back up again so
yeah it's it's i'm
i think it's i think it's had that kind
of passive influence i don't think
anyone wants to be the one to clone the
nemesis system though
it's not yeah it's not going to work
people cloned i'd be happy about it
nemesis system is one of them okay
it's so good i feel that way about the
arkham combat system you can put that in
anything and i'll love it like sleeping
dogs i was like yes
more of this it's such and that's a
really good example of a mechanic
because that's a mechanic that's very
surface level or kind of it's it's a
it's an interaction
combat mechanic that's not easy
that takes a while but you could
theoretically like change course on a
project you were
a third of the way into you could go
when batman came out you could be like
okay
that was good we're gonna we're gonna
but first
who did that first was it assassin's
creed or was it arkham
i feel like arkham yeah
i think it was arkham i think the first
assassin's creed their melee system was
was not that was it or maybe it was it
was
like assassin's creed it was definitely
but that was so i mean assassin's creed
came about 2007.
yeah so it wasn't it the great year
wasn't it 2006
it was seven it was the one where all
the games came out everything came out
right
[Laughter]
oh the magic bookshelf strikes again god
damn you mike with the book that is
relevant
again i'm gonna go back like when
i'm just gonna find out actually what
would be amazing if the book was called
who did it first the combat of of uh
the arkham games versus assassins but
it's just two pages
a book yeah i feel like it was awkward
but
um there are plenty of games that have
iterated on that too but i find that
that system so satisfying i mean
cross reference example of the game that
did that very nice
assassin's creed that's jesus
that's really nice isn't it it's not
nice it's the it's like the encyclopedia
thing
cool anyway sorry yes
you guys oh go ahead austin well we'll
keep this to one sentence it's just
there's a musical equivalent to what
you're describing
that i remember thinking about uh it was
about 20 years ago now
but when the matrix came out the score
was so distinctive and so unlike other
scores and it was this
incredible blend of like very kind of
slick
modern electronic synth sound design
with
very very kind of post-modern almost
classical
like like like late 20th century modern
classical
orchestral music in a way that to my era
is still kind of unsurpassed as a
as a musical hybrid of electronics with
traditional
orchestra and remember thinking this is
so distinct that i bet
it's going to have a legion of imitators
but but it's so
it's so perfectly ingrained with the
identity of the matrix
that you would have to be the person to
say like i know i'm making you know
a transformer movie or a marvel movie or
whatever i have to like
i know this has nothing to do with
anything like the matrix i'm just gonna
go ahead and just grab this
and and i think in to this day no one's
ever made a score that sounds like
their primary reference or inspiration
was the matrix it stands alone and
that's
so rare well no movie we remember anyway
right that's the thing is like i think
they're being derivative often is a way
of kind of knocking yourself off the
history books
yeah no that's that's that's true i
should say no
no kind of um successful or otherwise
kind of noteworthy or acclaimed or
whatever
kind of but it is it's the same i kept
thinking that same thing like who wants
to be the person that
has just like swap out the assets uh
but plug in their their nemesis i think
odyssey probably did it as well as you
could
and not feel like you're shamelessly
stealing from it but anyway it would be
it would be cool because there's a part
then
there's a little part of me that's like
i just said on a podcast that we're
gonna like
put out there that it's easy to do the
nemesis system
and now i kind of want to like test that
theory by trying to do it
in principle i'm sure yeah
yeah but but it's like i'm now gonna
actually have to go and like try and put
that in something at some point it's
easy in the way
academically interested in how you could
kind of try if i
wonder if you could do something similar
to that kind of an indie scale
because a lot of the i mean and even
then just the way they did it was so
clever i think mike mitchell just
announced his next game
make a matrix game please matrix game
with the matrix music
no i will steadfastly not use the matrix
music
don't you dare i don't want the music in
this to sound the thing like the matrix
i would i would actually like for
someone to do
because we've got the character art half
there already just from the last thing
so
this is this is tangents but but the uh
the first equilibrium came out and then
matrix crushed it
hey did equilibrium come out first
really yeah that's the one with the gun
genius dude oh so good is that what guns
look like to you you weird commonwealth
man
have you seen the movie because that's
how i have it to be fair
back me up troy please back me up that's
what they're doing in the movie right
and
their defense and their defense what was
the shorthand comment that they called
it
gun carter right gunkata so similar to
gung-fu which would be in john wick i
feel like i'm doing like a little austin
little
oddly enough you can trace it back
to and the composer for that movie
as mike reaches behind him in the
bookshelf
when we're done alana i need you to
watch the trailer of equilibrium and
then send me an apology because that was
a perfect admirer of the movie
oh [ __ ] who was it uh it was it was uh
it wasn't tay diggs
it was uh christian bill and who's bail
yeah
bail and who but who is his it's
basically a brave new world
speaking of all this huxley it's brave
new world yeah with
with guns that's not a good film you're
right who was the second lead in that
it's you could tell they thought they
were making a badass movie and just the
director just
and the dp there's a wrong camera
package wrong lenses
wrong would you say that you thought
that came out before the matrix
it did it was three years after no
well unless imdb is full of lies it was
stakes
mistakes 99 versus 2002 oh
my god i don't think that's by the way
there's no way in hell i'm not watching
that movie tonight now oh yeah dude
yeah you reminded me of its existence
man i need to
uh okay so i wanted to jump back to
austin what you were saying about people
you know being terrified to
even come close to replicating the
matrix this is a thing that
interestingly enough
um a lot of indie studios i think
don't recognize the importance of pr
people or marketing
so they often think i can do that myself
that's just drafting up an email and
sending it to press i can find a press
list
what does that matter they just
completely underestimate how important
that stuff is for getting your game out
there and unless it's something that
i've spoken about this before is
extremely shareable and can be
bite-sized and
shared with everyone like fez uh or like
a dream daddy
it's very difficult to get an indie game
to have traction and one of the things
that you see
uh studios do who definitely don't have
pr managers
is go this game is dark souls combined
with
whatever or like zelda combined with
whatever they
they don't market their games for what
they individually do they always just
say
we ripped this from this franchise this
from this franchise and that's what
we're putting in the headline and
because so many of them do it it's
really ineffective
but i figured that the reason that they
have to do that is a
it's cheaper to make a game in theory
uh if you are to to mike's point if a
lot of the
the made up cost of games is coming up
with a solid idea
and then actually putting it in motion
rather than spending time
figuring yeah it's less the idea than
the design that comes of the idea right
the kind of
yeah how do we actually make this kind
of thing yeah but you're absolutely
right yeah it'd save some time
yeah so i mean and i'll also interview
devs at pax we'll be like well we wanted
to make our first game after university
so we just picked two games we like and
combined them and sometimes it comes up
with really really cool stuff but i feel
like that is a
definitely a thing that indies are more
willing to do um we've gotten i'm
forgetting the name of the game there's
like one really dope game that was
literally just dark souls combined with
zelda and i was like
cool that's what you did that's what you
said in all of your interviews that's
what you intended to do and you made
this awesome indie thing because
sometimes taking risks for an indie
studio is a lot scarier but then i mean
we're at a point with triple a as well
where
a studio like ubisoft is iterating off
themselves
so much that have you guys seen the
review of ubisoft game
no i don't remember who whose website
it's on but it's just
a review of ubisoft game let me find it
it's very good
it sounds hilarious no title just
ubisoft game
it's like presumably it's every ubisoft
game right
but sorry mike go ahead
that's cool i was just saying to what to
what alana was saying though
it's it's also about it's just about
managing this like you're you're on as
an india you can't be risky on all
levels so sometimes you just have to
choose like
here's the two things i'm going to be
risky about you know it's like
in john wick's case threshold is
actually lower or higher for
indies than for aaa because there's
theoretically
less at stake uh in terms of overall
budget or size of team or whatever
like canton are you so sorry are you
saying indy's less risky or aaa's less
risky no i'm saying
i'm saying there's powerful incentive
for triple a's to be less risky
oh yeah indies yeah for sure for sure
what the hell is this alana pierce
first i know we've all heard of ubisoft
game and if you haven't you've been
living under a rock
uh it's basically just ubisoft is the
story of a main character a gruff or
sassy white man who's really good at
parkour killing and killing while doing
parkour
it's basically like a review uh
on it's on point in clickbait that i've
always really loved that just
combines all ubisoft games the message
of the main story seems kind of lost
unfortunately which is a shame because
ubisoft have clearly put so much money
and effort into polishing ubisoft game
it feels like they were afraid to make a
statement in the main story
i i want to point out by the way here's
another here's another
article from this one this site feels
like an offshoot of the onion
they're so good though if you've not
like devote a couple of hours to digging
into this at some point try because it
is hilarious
here's here's just two others that you
can see here animal crossing and oral
history of the 2020 bunny day massacre
um and then opinion female gamers simply
don't have the reflexes to be called a
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] at a professional level
what i love is this ubisoft game review
is six years old
and everything's is like still
aged well yeah what was their metacritic
though i want to see what they actually
scored it would they give it they gave
it a score but the final line is ubisoft
also makes some absolutely incredible
smaller games like raymond legends child
of light and valiant hearts a great war
but nobody plays those so whatever
really do you think i've already played
that game have i talked on this
show before about my favor my most the
thing that i love about uber
one that i find fascinating about
ubersoft maybe love's too strong a word
did you they have a department that's
job is to predict
future trends have you heard about this
um and it explains every ubisoft game
once you know it
so ubisoft i've i've i was i saw a i saw
a talk actually by uh the woman who
heads it up
and basically they have a department
internally where they're basically
tracking what they think is going to be
the hot button issue the discussion
about five years into the future so what
they do then is they try and
make their game about or at least have
the aesthetics of they would just
like too early with the division just a
little well that's the thing
is once you realize this you go back and
you look at all of their ubisoft
aaa games and they basically have
successfully predicted most major
cultural shifts that have occurred in
the last skull and bombs six years
actually
pirates uh have made a big comeback
recently
no but but seriously though did that
game come out
no okay um but like no seriously though
if you look at like you know
where the the watchdogs brexit game that
is
coming out at some point if you look at
like far cry 5 with its white
supremacist stuff like
they were predicting the kind of
discussions that would be happening
and that's for a triple a studio they
have to know they have to like
if they want to be on the three years
ago or two years ago they have to be so
far ahead and that's
and genuinely that's amazing to me so i
like genuinely like uber soft
announcements to me
are now like nostradamus if i see them
announce a game coming out in a year or
two there's the title of the podcast
it was something else for thomas
i was going to do psychedelics and stuff
but mike bithell just just slammed dunk
the whole thing is like here's what it
is guys
well actually in anonymous is the real
the real twist there
that's what i'm saying i have 2021
vikings are coming back that's all i'm
saying that's the
uh first of all vikings i was onto that
[ __ ]
i fell off the whole game of thrones are
you about to be a viking
but yeah i mean i know very impassioned
leading into this viking right
i was i was i was i was an early adopter
of
vikings before i was in the vikings
before it was cool hipster glasses on
wait wait wait up he's got him he's got
the glasses
i feel like you need a sniper hat though
to really before
yeah i the i was watching i remember
watching
the first episode of vikings was like
holy [ __ ] dude i'm totally into this
because not at all what i thought it was
going to be
um read an article uh
with uh what's his nuts um
john a blank on his name uh i'm not
familiar with his nuts blue eyed dude
that's just
has his have his nuts ever like composed
music for a major movie
yes or actually there's a book about him
right now i'm ready
i did it did cross my mind of do i have
any history books about vikings if i
don't
annoyingly jesus it's a magic book you
have every book
uh but i i was super into that whole
show and then all of a sudden we saw
everything starting to skew
and even when we were tying this back
into shadow of order it was like
when they were looking originally for
for other directors they were like what
if we did
someone who this person did episode of
vikings um
because shows just change through
directors uh and keep one show runner to
kind of
give it some cohesion um but i was super
into that now all of a sudden everyone's
like ah vikings is such a great show and
like i was like dude game of thrones is
tame man i watched them pull some dude's
lungs out from his back
uh on an episode season three blood
eagle watch that [ __ ]
um it's just such a great great show um
if you want to see something really
really cool go on youtube
um a friend of mine does the does the
score for that show
and they did a performance of it at the
krakow film
music festival in poland where it's
literally it's about
14 15 000 people in the audience and and
the composer he's conducting the
orchestra and tina guo is playing
electric cello
and einer selvik who is the uh vocalist
from wardrunner who's essentially a
a a viking a modern viking
but he also is um he's in the show i
think
uh i don't know i've never watched it so
i don't know but i'm pretty sure he's on
screen as well
but he's involved in the music and they
give this performance where he's singing
and playing and tina's playing and then
there's a whole big orchestra in choir
and it it's like six minutes of just raw
fury uh it's it's absolutely amazing and
it
it just it's like you know
one of those that you watch it and
you're like i i like
all the comments are you know my beard
just grew a beard you know
i get that i completely i feel that
right now
i think it was the final episode of
season four uh
or the next to last episode of season
four
that is one of the greatest episodes of
television i've ever seen and
and the last episode of
whatever most recent one is that season
five season six is one of the best
directed episodes of television i've
ever seen there's like two
amazing like true i don't care if you
like the show
at all just from a pure sen from from a
performance
uh cinematography directorial standpoint
it is flawless it is is there like a is
there like a guide
so i've never i've never got around to
watching but i want to do i start season
one and go through do i skip something
what do i do
no you need to watch all of it because
the whole thing will tie back to [ __ ]
from season one and season one is like
you can tell that history did not
believe in this show they were gonna do
it
but it was like it it feels like
somebody did this
made this show which is kind of like mr
robot did there a couple of
other uh or what was the first uh that
really kicked this off um
the one with uh uh mads mickelson
um hannibal hannibal hannibal
they they shot the show completely like
who wants it
and then they put it and then like cbs
or whoever bought it
um so they did the same thing i think
with with vikings where they shot any
canada and they were like
who wants this show and history's like
[ __ ] it we'll take it but there was no
money
and then it did great and so every
episode every season
the production value just just almost
exponentially doubles or triples it's
it's crazy what it does
even game of thrones you can see that
happening though like like season one
compared to later on
it's very small drastic yeah um this
design it's
nuts um okay to bring it back to next
gen which was
intended to be the topic uh you guys
will also
watch travis oh yeah travis
yeah that unreal demo was amazing
absolutely amazing
who said that was it a game is like too
bad it's not actually a game was that
not actually a game that they were
showing
no i mean it's just the demo that they
made oh
i want to play that game though well the
one thing that got me about that demo
is that i mean if you've got 40 million
austin if you've got 10 million 20
million we can we can pull our resources
i'm going to use all my my john wick hex
uh
residuals advances and are you seriously
criticizing your payment on john wick x
on this publicly i'm not criticizing i'm
celebrating
you've turned me into an investor a
studio investor and i'm very grateful
for that fact
as long as you don't mind if i just give
you a slight smaller amount up front
sorry uh no about it was that uh yeah
sorry no no no i was gonna even though
it's it's
to me it was clearly a demo because
people don't tend to make games where
the environments are
that incredibly detailed and those
artists that epic puts that much time
into making those environments and then
you just speed past them and never look
at any of them
i feel like that is not generally how
resources are distributed with any
aaa game because especially if you know
your players probably aren't going to be
looking at the things
that are around them because you're
moving too fast through it you're flying
through it
that's what's wild about that demo is is
there's obviously an enormous amount of
artwork involved an enormous amount of
like our effort
but a massive part of that is that a lot
of those environmental pieces of art
those environmental bricks they built
their environment from were scanned they
weren't
they were photographs essentially so
that's where it gets
they looked like i think the the the the
rock structures at least were
photogrammetry or at least
obviously used that that would still
don't get me wrong that's not it's like
it's like mocap like there's still a lot
of very skilled artists and technicians
after the act
but it does speed through the process so
yeah i was going to say isn't that
could see more about next year that was
that was sort of the central
selling point i thought wasn't it that
like you can create something of this
fidelity
without spending 10 million hours like
you might have before
to building it from the bottom up well
it's the crazy thing is
lod is the loading like which we can get
into week
so level of details so you've seen this
when you're running around in gta
and you are far away from something you
notice it's like low poly and then as
you get closer it
it fills in or when you're playing a
game in the cutscene loads
and the characters are all blobby messes
for a few frames until they click into
place
so it's how it's how games render stuff
basically is they
is essentially for every object so a car
in gta there would be multiple levels of
detail of that car that'd be the model
the mesh that's shown to you when you're
right up close
that'd be the version that they show to
you maybe when you're 10 meters away 50
meters away 100 meters away
right up until it's like a cube
basically when you're
x miles away flying a helicopter over
overhead this is the same thing you were
talking about last time with the whole
guns and call of duty right like the gun
that i pick up is not the gun that's in
there
because yeah different yeah that's i
mean and it's all games so like um
last of us right the version of the
character model that's
you're playing in the cutscenes is going
to be different to the version that i'm
running around as as a player
and is going to be different than the
version you see from 100 miles away
for a wide shot because they they want
to put those policies into the
environment
the big thing with the unreal pitch and
the thing that i'm
having arguments with tech people about
right now of kind of trying to figure it
out is
they're claiming that uh they're going
to make lodding essentially invisible as
a process
right now if you want to make different
lods of
a model there are tools you can use that
can kind of trim the time but it's still
a manual process where you're having to
make all that
what they're claiming on the unreal side
is all of that would be automated
so you you basically make a super high
res mesh like you would for a movie
and then the magic elves that unreal
turn that into all the different lods
that would be needed and then that you
can
itself would do that that's super that's
what they're claiming
and and and what and so yeah so i mean
literally the the team called today uh
before games
was all the artists going this is
amazing we we should play with this this
sounds really cool
and all the tech guys going i don't know
if that's true that sounds right
it's too good to be true well that's but
that's what i use but that's right
but why i said on the call and i think
it's true is the great thing about game
development
is everything's ridiculous and
impossible right up until the moment
where it becomes
completely
yeah and it could be one of those
moments and if it is one of those
moments then that's incredibly exciting
for me i mean just for the indie side
because of the amount of work it saves
us
right now realistically i can't produce
a game of a triple a fidelity
partially because of all of this work
doing lods like i can't make
environments that are massive because of
the amount of technical challenges to
doing that
and you're saying this which is same for
you yeah in theory like in theory
theoretically it's possible that like a
triple a studio
that is going to do something like
assassin's creed
this like triple i studio this like
super indie studio
it brings us all up here in theory well
look think of it this way right so
video games right let's think of a gun
the the quintessential building block of
all video games a gun right
like a uh i know a gun from halo david
cage would like to join this
conversation by the way
the the assault rifle from halo right
imagine imagine that just like a generic
space gun
the way that we as a game studio would
make that is obviously you do the
concept art you start modeling
you model you model the gun at like
stupidly high resolution
uh in a way that never could be used in
a game and that takes
maybe for like probably for a triple a
pipeline that's going to be taking
in the low number of weeks one week two
weeks depending on
exactly like how much of a hero prop
this is okay
then you have to right now in the
current process
you have to turn that into something you
can use in the game which means you have
to
bake down a lot of detail into normal
maps you have to make different polygon
counts of that model
you have to figure out how to render
that model in real time you have to make
shadow maps and
i mean inclusion maps you have to do a
bunch of technical stuff on top of that
before it goes into the gun and looks
cool and all of that work
is massively invisible to the player by
definition it's designed to be invisible
we don't want you to
spot that we've swapped out the gun for
a crap gun because it's further away
from you
that would defeat the entire purpose but
yeah in theory this is
make the asset and you're done and if
that's true that's incredible that's
that's that saves so much technical
artistry in the middle
it's it sounds ridiculous but everything
does until it's real so does that
make jobs then is is there people that
could potentially
does that make them obsolete it makes a
certain amount of
it make some skill sets obsolete if it's
true um but then people would reskill
reskills is i mean that's the backbone
of the games i think i'm pretty sure i
even said on this my first job in the
industry is a
is a .03 millisecond button press in
unity now
um that's that's how the industry moves
so you always have to be reskilling
ultimately and people sometimes get left
behind but
no generally yeah they'll just go into
other jobs doing other
cool stuff a lot of things that like
unreal seems to be like a very
it's kind of like that's what the big
boys use and even though there's a lot
of big games that are made on unity one
of the things that's great about unity
is the accessibility that it has
especially to smaller studios
does this kind of undermine what the
the place that unity has in the
marketplace for
indie developers i until i've played
with i don't know like it's
it's a it's a different pipeline i know
theoretically it's a it's a
it's a completely different way of doing
art in video games so
until we've all i mean we'll probably
grab it and start playing with it and
see how it fits into what we do but like
i think a lot of developers are the same
but also on the indie side we've talked
about risk taking earlier
knowing an engine is a big risk right so
starting a new engine can
introduce a bunch of problems that's
what all of the platform holders kind of
rely
or sorry what beauty and unreal
specifically rely on is you're going to
be loyal because
it's easier if you want to if you want
to keep making games quickly you use the
thing your team already
knows and has training in that's why
both unreal and unity beyond obviously
also being lovely people
provide so many of their tools to
universities because if you get people
using that from the start of their
careers
then that's the thing that they're going
to keep using throughout their careers
rather than having to re-skill
to your to your point troy the um the
i also was looking at unreal's like on
their
on their site um and they they announced
as part of the tech demo
that uh for the rollout of the new
iteration of the engine any studio that
uses it
um the first million dollars of revenue
from a game
um is royalty free to unreal also oh wow
um it's a it's definitely a play it's
definitely absolutely
i was like for indies that's also
particularly lucrative i would think i
mean of course it's a player for them
that's still just a business but the one
thing that i wanted to ask
i'm not complaining as someone who would
probably financially massively benefit
from that if you did make an unreal game
i'm not
i'm definitely not complaining but it's
not technically
uh it's i feel like it's being spoken
about like it's next-gen
tech i feel like that especially
considering how
iterative consoles have become and how
much i feel like the landscape is going
to change with you know
the pro and the x coming sort of
mid-cycle for this uh generation of
consoles i feel like we're going to keep
seeing more of that but i wanted to say
like this
this tech demo isn't technically
next-gen tech it is literally just
a change to an engine is there any
reason why
this like it like a game could not be
made for playstation 4 or for xbox one x
using this on this side but didn't
wasn't the video specifically saying
this is our engine running on ps5
it was that's how yes but i don't feel
like it couldn't
necessarily function maybe the engine's
using the architecture of
is is inherent to the architecture of
the new system so there's a few there's
a few reasons yeah there is some there
is some technical stuff that's been
with the new platforms and this is where
i'm going to dance around some ndas but
basically
the the architecture of the new hardware
i think most of this is out there and
whatever it is and i'll get in trouble
for that's fine
um like the yeah the way the
architecture sets up the the way these
future graphics cards are working yes
you could build a pc that will run this
and of course
you will be able to because you best
believe fortnight's going to make use of
all this technology right so they're
going to want it on
platforms but in terms of um the ray
tracing in particular there's a lot of
stuff that's happened with graphics
cards recently that's kind of empowering
right right
it's so good and and that's a big part
of the unreal demo is them
claiming that ray tracing is kind of an
intrinsic thing
not having to bake light maps every
environment you've ever walked into in a
video game with very few exceptions
the creators of that level had to leave
a computer running for about an hour to
render all the shadows on the walls
that's gold you've got to place the sun
man that's
like when i saw someone i saw it for uh
detroit become human they they basically
just
like pulled the engine apart and showed
me exactly where all the light sources
were and were like
you don't understand how expensive
lighting is and we can't have this light
be too bright because then it screws up
the whole scene and it's just it's like
mine field of putting but that's what
i'm talking about
this stuff changes everything because
yeah ray tracing in theory
means infinite numbers of light
technically there's no such thing as
infinite obviously
but like there it becomes easier um so
no there's
there you go the door's a perception um
yeah so
it's trippy but yeah i get the
victim the other the other big favorite
alana is um
is like the platform baseline when
you're making games you're
you're not necessarily unless you're cry
tech you're not making games for like
the best ever computer
you're making games for where people
will actually buy your game
so having a generational jump means that
up till now if i want to put ray tracing
into a game i'm making a decision to
basically make a feature for
five percent 10 to the audience with
control if you're going to build a
marketing campaign around that it's
worth putting that in for me it makes no
sense
whereas now with ps5 and xbox i'm going
to be able to just
assume i can have that before i can
the other one is ssd which is massive
and no one's no one's paying enough
attention to which is the the
fast loading which is completely
redefining
it's going to redefine how we play games
in terms of the open world and fast
track like fast travel
doesn't matter anymore in terms of like
i mean even the structures though like
uh final fantasy vii remake i feel like
it masks a lot of loading
by giving you like like things that are
very obvious to me that i feel like you
know a lot of people are just like why
did that take so long like
something like opening a door can be a
button press that takes a really long
time
yeah more than it should or you have to
walk slowly down a hallway right when
you can run everywhere else
inching through a gap in a wall to hide
the loading screen
it's the gears of war taking a phone
call and having to walk really slowly
thing that it's
uh even in final fantasy 7 which i feel
like that game is beautiful and is
pretty big and is very very detailed
when you get into the
sandboxy areas it's not particularly
open world but uh the the loading there
is so obvious that i found it
a little bit and that's done like to be
clear like there'll be some probably
some transition games in the
in the overlap when we first play the
first few games that do it but
generally in in the next era we're not
gonna have loading times anymore
and that's going to redefine the shape
of how we play games and how
games even work because right now you
know there's lots of
systems and ways that games are made in
order to like
hide loading as you say and kind of
space
that spider-man demo is crazy like yeah
that's going to be the default
sorry jumping in very quickly i'm sorry
i'm just excited man i'm just excited
about the tech
i am too yeah i have to jump off but
like last week and you
you guys you three people this whole
after dark thing
oh you watch you're you're you're you
are a fan that's great that's great
uh so i uh well are you are you gonna
tune in to aftertalk
personally i think it's a great spin-off
show and i look forward to it
uh so i'll let you guys get to creating
that content um
thank you for always hosting this alana
you're incredible
um yay video games making games this
hard um
i'll see you guys next week is that what
we're doing was that an allen watts
quote
that was an alan watts quote as a matter
of fact we'll probably wrap the show up
pretty soon but yeah we'll see you next
week troy thank you
bye guys see you later troy hi austin
how much longer
finally he's gone geez uh yeah
as we're slowly inching towards our
spin-off show a little more without troy
each time
yeah uh i'm i'm i'm good for a few
minutes i i can i can i
i can see us through to the end i
suspect um
almost an hour anyway so it's not a big
deal but uh yeah yeah i mean i i wanted
to talk about some of the the
expectations for next-gen and that like
you know kind of up until this uh unreal
demo came out
i was of the mindset and then a lot of
the community had been saying it too
that
the uh graphical updates especially from
the xbox conference i don't know if you
guys saw that
um didn't seem to be as significant as
we have been
used to in previous uh console cycles
which is it's going to slow down anyway
at this point because
games have gotten so attractive you know
it's not it's not we're not playing in
different amounts of bits at this point
it's it's such a different landscape to
what it was
even a decade ago really um but no
because because
16 colors right because things are
more iterative and i'm still expecting
that to be
you know probably four versions of an
xbox in the next console cycle
and in theory maybe they'll eventually
let us
just upgrade a graphics card i don't
know if that's part of the plan
but i feel like one thing that a lot of
uh
people don't consider when it comes to
how
games look is that consoles are in
theory
kind of holding every everything back
but at the same time
so are people with just base level pcs
right so
in theory right now we could be getting
games that run a lot better than they
currently do but they're going to make
games for the consoles because that's
what most people have
uh despite what i feel like the pc
audience tries to say most people are
still playing on console
technically even more on mobile but
that's a separate thing
yeah actually i was i was gonna chime
that in just say like
when you say consoles are holding things
back it's it's interesting because
there's vastly more mobile
gamers than any other category almost
like oh i've gone blurry it's almost a
completely different
landscape like i almost consider mobile
gaming to be totally separate to the
other two even
just but they're but they're converging
because you know it's like if you look
at um
i mean again just sort of hopefully this
doesn't come across
as a plug but um pathless is um
obviously coming out um as a playstation
title
um um you know that was already
announced as a ps4 game when they first
announced it but um but it's also
announced as part of apple arcade
and so like they had to be able to
figure out how in the hell can we make
this thing take advantage of
the uh you know current gen
technology but but current gen on
apple devices and current gen sony
devices is that
is that a possible target to hit and i
do believe it is
uh i mean you have to make very
calculated decisions
um and uh but uh but uh so yeah
anyway just a s it's a strange thing
because they're like two different
industries but they are
it looks like it seems to me that
apple's working very hard to try to
converge them as best they can yeah it's
i mean touch screen controls have always
sucked to me but like
papers please is probably one of my
favorite games ever
and that's a game that i think i've only
ever played on an ios device but
yeah my point was i feel like i've seen
a lot of the community say that they're
disappointed that we've not had as many
graphical updates
as they expect or they're not blown away
by everything we've seen of next-gen yet
and uh i kind of just want to wanted to
say that i feel like yeah things are
slowing down
um and things are getting more iterative
but it's also until you get a major
change to an engine like this unreal
update um not that photogrammetry wasn't
already a thing like i know um ea relied
on that really heavily with with
battlefront specifically is like a huge
part of like making sure that
everything star wars looks very
realistic hey i mentioned star wars
looks very realistic and that game is
like the correct scale
uh it's something that that
we can really only do so much like in
theory if you want to make a 10-minute
demo you can make that look absolutely
incredible but the minute that you want
to make a larger game
you got to take stuff out to put other
stuff in it's just not as simple as i
feel like a lot of the community thinks
it is and that's probably why
if you're not blown away by what you've
seen of next-gen footage so far um
it's because you kind of can't be at
this point but and also i think we've
been trained
i'm sorry no i was good i was gonna say
we've been trained to kind of
look at kind of i feel like the industry
always does this with every with every
next generation where we've trained the
audience
to have to basically like downgrade in
their head from what we show them at e3
and we've we've kind of we show them
something and we've kind of taught them
to be a little bit skeptical and go okay
well obviously when this hits full
production they
as you said the the vertical slice is
not gonna be indicative it's gonna
come down a bit um and yeah and it will
and with this i think it will come down
less uh and the other thing of course is
the first games of a console generation
are
the ugliest by a long way and yeah you
know
by the time what we're seeing right now
yeah yeah right now you're saying
that's true of your scene you're seeing
perfect dark zero you know these are
yeah these are not the games they're
going to define the aesthetic of this
ryze is really pretty though so that
came still
rise the oh yeah it was crytek xbox
exclusive
launch title that came still i think
unless i'm just remembering it's still
really pretty but yeah that was
basically
what i'm trying to say is this stuff
takes time and seeing the disappointment
i think largely comes from people
psychologically
um ruling out the fact that the pro and
the xbox one x
have existed in this life cycle which
has changed things a bit but also that
our expectations have changed because
the way things are being iterated on
graphically is in theory a little bit
slower
or it feels like it's slower when when
you say the um
that disparity between um
you know the the small little vertical
slice demo
um and scaling up to production and also
kind of
connected with the early phase of
release of a new console
would you say that that's also true like
mike on a technical level
like the initial users of a new engine
or a major update to an engine isn't
that going to have also the same
the same uh symptoms basically because
we haven't we collectively like
developers i i i over extend myself by
saying we
uh uh but um people like you
uh are still learning all the
minutia of what makes it uh uh
really really sing sure and then it
would you know same with unreal no
different than the hardware of
a ps5 or whatever right yeah it's not a
far stretch
to say and also games take time to make
right like anything you've seen in an
unreal 5 demo
that was news to you know the vast
majority of developers obviously there
will be people who've had early access
to that but
it's still going to be a few probably a
year or two before you actually
that's probably i would guess as is
normally the case
most of the launch titles will be on the
on
unreal four i would assume um and and
likewise like franchise stuff sometimes
those jumps are really scary and
i think i think batman's the one that's
a great example of like
the batman frog um the arkham games were
in unreal three
way past the point where unreal four
came out like i feel like they shipped
they they did dev cycles after that
because it's what they built in up to
that point and
again risk management right that's
something we talked about they made it
work
and they made it work and you can always
you can always get more out of an engine
you know there's always there's always a
few more tricks you can find a few more
gimmicks you can kind of work out to
kind of make it sing um
and it's it's you know it's and that's
demonstrated by the kind of the
underwhelming thing is like
to the average player that unreal five
demo probably looks about as good as the
photogrammetry stuff in battlefield
right like you're
you're seeing that and you maybe aren't
being blown away by it
so yeah we will be playing on real four
games for quite some time i would have
thought
um yeah i just feel like this particular
console cycle is an interesting one but
it's also obviously hurt by the fact
that we're not having any
in-person stuff like i think i mentioned
to you guys i've done a couple of
previews remotely and they're really bad
because it's over discord and the game
looks bad and there's lag it's just such
a terrible way to cover games and
right now what is that is keely has
summer game fest i think it's cold and
then ign
has summer of games and i always want to
be like when you people are naming these
things are you aware that there is
a different hemisphere it's winter in
australia
do they just not get to partake the
whole southern hemisphere is just like
summer i gotta wait till december
here's actually forgetting on honest
question for you about that though
because i've thought about i've thought
about that actually um
randomly here and there something like
this will make me wonder that
um but here's a question for you because
like the population of australia is like
the same as southern california like
yeah uh so out of
yeah yeah exactly like it's it's the
percentage of people
for whom summer is relevant like if you
look at if you look at
essentially the entire northern
hemisphere that's where the overwhelming
entire human population uh live it's not
just america obviously so my question is
is that something that you whether it's
right or not or whether that's sort of
egocentric on us northern hemisphere
rights
uh the question is do you this just
random trivia but
do you find you have kind of by
before you ever moved here did you just
was that an
auto adjustment that you kind of got
indoctrinated to make because everything
was relative to um
you know games media in the bay area or
in l.a
or like london even in australia
do you remember summer of arcade
it was basically maybe an xbox live
a digital event i guess it's like back
out of yeah
um in australia it was called winter of
arcade so they did localize it because
you know it's
sure the population is lesser but it's
still millions of
people so the only thing that my brain
knows
is white christmas and that's because
i've seen so
many um films that have a white
christmas so that's the only reason that
i really like
just automatically know that it's winter
at that time of year in this
hemisphere is because of all the movies
i've seen because there are still a lot
of americans i meet who
like i've been told i was lying when i
told someone that it was the opposite
season in australia they're like i don't
believe you how does that work it's like
is it spheres this is how it happens
it's just like that sounds like [ __ ]
so axial tilt uh i don't you don't you
don't hear a lot of uh
axial tilters in the same camp as flat
earthers that's true not quite as many
but
definitely seasons are a lie yeah uh but
no this stuff
it is to get back to summer game first
and
summer of games or whatever they're
calling them uh sorry to everyone in the
southern hemisphere shout out to you
going in the winter out there it's a
tough time
snows in australia fun fact a lot of
people don't know that uh but
yeah i feel like it's it's a really
interesting time as well because again
people aren't seeing things in person so
you can't read the journalists or the
youtubers or whatever tell you
how good things actually look we have to
see everything streamed
so that is absolutely worth noting as
well um when things are streamed
a lot of streams are only in 1080 and a
lot of your monitors are only in 1080
anyway so
a lot of the time it's really difficult
for you to actually get a hold of what
something looks like until you see it in
person
in 2020 we just don't really have the
option to do this stuff any other way um
i just feel like a lot of people are
crumbled out next gen and i'm like no no
no no i feel like you're getting ahead
of yourself here what we're seeing right
now is not what we're going to see over
time
what you're seeing right now is based on
expectations that you have
from previous generations where yeah now
things graphically are going to shift
less dramatically but it'll still be
happening and it's
to like what mike said some of the
updates that we'll see that people
aren't
uh talking about as much is getting rid
of loading screens
uh rather than just but forza motorsport
seven already looks perfect like sure
it's gonna it's gonna be smaller uh as
things go forward but
also it is a historical thing that we've
always said
i remember when half-life two came out
and as an industry we said right
that's as good as games happening
it's done and that and you know what
we'll be looking back at this stuff now
and final fantasy
really we thought final fantasy 7 remake
was like the pinnacle
um yeah it's just to continue so weird
how that works that i had that with
64 games i was like this is perfect and
then i play
uh rare replay and you see them there
and you're like oh yeah this is how it
looks and i went back and played them on
64. and was like this looks garbage
because your brain remembers things
looking better than they actually do as
well
oh yeah of course everything looks the
way the remastered version looks
like the good old days and we didn't get
smarter that's still the same like we
still are gonna we're still gonna look
back on this stuff
the same way and make the same mistakes
on this conversation and hear what we
said about final fantasy vii
that's what's up you know what a really
um you know what a really aggressive one
of those for me was system shock 2
where i i remember that game being so
visceral and and realistic and
and in going back and replaying it like
a decade later
i was shocked at how it just had not
aged even the movement felt so clunky
and
and the and the the very weird sort of
slow-mo
of uh the npcs and the enemies and
whatever and it was just it was funny
how like your brain
mythologizes things about five seconds
after the experience is over
and then just continues to build on the
method the like mythological
you know hologram of the thing instead
of the real thing and it's like you're
in a game of telephone with your own
memory
from the instant the event has passed
and
yeah as a side note that's why
when when uh the fact that eyewitness
testimony carries so much
uh weight and the criminal justice
system is [ __ ]
bonkers for that reason it is the most
demonstrably
fallible source of evidence that you
could possibly come up with and they
don't count the sniffer dogs there's
real evidence
he tracked where the man walked with his
nose yeah yeah dogs don't hold off in
court he's like what
but he did such a good job can you trust
our eyes are you joking
not to mention that they trust um like
dogs
for people like with severe allergies
and things like that where it could kill
them to
you know like i remember watching a tv
special about that where they
they there was a girl like a very young
kid like five six years old who had such
a severe peanut allergy that even just
ambiently in the air like if she smelled
peanut butter um like from a bakery
that alone could give her that
anaphylactic reaction so she had a dog
that if she was out in public the dog
would walk like 10 15 feet ahead of her
and if it sat
randomly she knew to go the other way
wow um
and it's like if you're willing to
entrust that level of
life-savingness you'd think that um you
would trust the fidelity of a crime
it's certainly better than a human
[ __ ] eyewitness testimony especially
when someone was
hysterical and afraid and already kind
of not operating normally the dogs were
robbed but one of my favorite things
about uh
vr i don't know if i've mentioned this
on the podcast before is that uh the way
that you remember vr
is different to the way that you
remember most other video games because
your brain is still having this
basically cognitive battle of thinking
that vr is real
so they've done a bunch of studies about
this where you will remember
um vr like it is an actual memory you
had rather than experience you had of
playing something
so you can generally remember a vr
experience really really vividly
uh you can see that image as though it
is an image you saw with your own eyes
because i guess it was if you can't see
anything else
so it means that you can remember
environments better you can navigate
better
and you can generally like without
having to look at a map uh know exactly
where to go in vr
or you know not play a game for a month
and pick it up and still recognize where
to go
much better than you'd be able to in a
game that you're playing on a monitor
which i think is just so
so so cool because the whole point of vr
is that technology has gotten
beyond us in that what we are doing is
consciously
tricking ourselves into thinking
something is real knowing our brain
even though we consciously know it's not
real is too stupid to keep up
that's why you get sick your brain's
like i should be moving
i should definitely be walking right now
why am i not walking and i get really
bad vr motion sickness which is
your brain's like must be poison must be
poison get it out
i'm definitely i've been dropped i need
to get rid of this immediately it's i
just think it's so dark that like we're
literally beyond our own conscious
comprehension of
of what that technology is it's so cool
and i mean that's the real next gen
it's true next gen was in us all along
the arts i got to uh i got to give a
play a test of um
what became um the um
lone echo of ready at dawn um
they were doing vr prototyping for it
years ago
and and it was all zero g you know
floating through
through space station where you have the
the gloves and you're kind of pushing
off of surfaces and floating
you know however and and i remember they
said uh you
you know the all i did is just put put
it on me and push here
you know can you look down push off and
then look up and see yourself drifting
towards the ceiling and
i remember being re because i had always
been so skeptical i was like it's never
going to work it's never
it's just too much between peripherals
and setting up the cameras and and the
cables and i just thought this is never
going to become anything mainstream i
i i i i i i i hope i'm wrong because it
blew me away because what happened i was
using vr every day right now
every single day i mean it's obviously
the quest was a big game changer yeah it
is for sure yeah
um but i um i remember the thing was i
was talking to
um the uh the the guy who was kind of um
my handler for this uh demo and he said
um
uh see that sort of porthole in the
um in the wall you know i'm on the
opposite wall he said can you push off
and aim for it and then just drift
through it and this whole time i'd been
in kind of like some sort of zero g
chamber and there was no sense of
context and it was just a tech demo so
there's no like story or setup or
anything
and i remember i pushed and i
successfully managed to hit this little
hole and i drifted out and then i was
like [ __ ] in space
over saturn and my whole face just
instantly started sweating yeah and like
my palms but i was exhilarated but it
was like because i remember it gave me
goosebumps
i just said this this is the most
transcendent gaming experience i've
probably ever had in my life it
instantly made me a vr
convert but it was amazing to me how my
body
was a hundred percent convinced it was
real for about a second
and i just was like i mean literally i
take off the thing and my hair is
soaked and i'm like holy [ __ ] i mean it
looked like i was just getting out of a
pool and taking off scuba diving i
remember
minecraft in vr for ign and had to take
breaks every probably 15 minutes because
that game especially
a very scary in vr i don't generally
find minecraft scary but when you see
the size of those spiders and they look
like they're actually in front of you
terrifying like seeing a creeper in vr
and being like oh my god it's huge
it's like awful but yeah my body with
that one really just rejected minecraft
hard so i was having to take it off and
like take a breather and have some water
and then put it back on the first game
in vr i ever played was team fortress 2.
and every time there's an explosion your
body just flies and that's it's
it's awful but again very cool testament
to what we're doing to our brains i just
think it's so dope
uh closing fun fact because i love
talking about this i've actually done
zero g
i have done a zero g flight really like
the vomit comet yes
i've done a vomit vomit comet as they
call it nobody vomited um
and it is just
so difficult to move because your
velocity is all off right so like
you could try to stay still but the
minute you touch a wall
you're just gonna slingshot in the other
direction so even trying to just stay in
one position
when you're doing that is is so hard to
do
i just feel like we don't give the
astronauts enough credit you know
were you were you like reviewing zero g
for ign
i give zero g as an experience a nine
out of ten it was a particular producer
at ign on what's basically like the
production
sales team uh he pitched a series that
was basically doing
extreme things while playing video games
which was definitely
just so this particular dude had an
excuse to do all these cool extreme
things on ign's budget successful pitch
it went through
somebody sponsored it but mine was to
play
um one two switch in zero g that's
amazing
so we're trying to play one two switch
you know zero g
and inside of a plane that's had it's in
it's removed
and the gyros even work in that that was
our first
uh concern was is the gyro even going to
work jared does still
work for the most part there were like
some
some issues but i mean the biggest
problem we had was like it's me and
naomi kyle holding joycon
and that we would leave the actual like
switch screen
to float but then if anything touches it
it's gone
so you just can't see where it's gone
and it's so hard to get anything back
it's so hard to move it's crazy but also
one of the coolest things i've ever done
no vomiting involved it's one of my
biggest regrets is i was invited onto
one of those once and i didn't do it
really yeah i showed them were you
unable or did you turn it down
yes the timings didn't work out but like
yeah that would have been great i think
it is
like a thousand dollars a person or
something it was around that
that kind of thing yeah i think yeah
it's a lot of money but yeah very
very cool stuff if you ever get to do it
and hopefully one day they do just pair
vr into that
probably that's the future can you
imagine that if you you're going for the
most
unique amazing experience you're like i
want to do this one in vr
like i don't want to actually see
anything i did say i was next to the one
window in the plane and they were like
we recommend that you don't look out of
the window so naturally i'm like i'ma
look out that [ __ ] window and i did
and when you're nose-diving i would
prefer to look at anything else like
that's gonna be terrible the plane is
literally
nose diving and then you see the you
know the horizon
and it's like that and you're like oh
that's not good
because when you're not thinking for ign
yeah seven hours that video
top ten ign employee deaths one zero g
um all right and wouldn't even be number
one that's the thing it's like number
three
i have the scar on my hand probably
can't see it like right here
because one of the first uh features i
ever wrote for them they made me cut
open an amiibo with a hacksaw
a lot harder than you would think
they're very solid we're like we just
want to see what's inside it so i open
it up and it was a kirby
and i yeah a very very big scar of blood
for that company man
and then the comments were like this is
stupid why did you do this i don't know
what they may be i don't know i don't
know very uh alongside my ranking the
amiibo
in terms of attractiveness article did a
lot of very important stuff there but uh
before we wrap shall anyone have any
clothing
closing thoughts they wanted to share on
vr one was obviously
my big one was obviously hold your
horses
we're all acting like next-gen as [ __ ]
and ugly and i think we're off base
um no i'm excited i i'm excited both
both like in the unreal demo where
they're you know unreal also famously
um always had somewhat lackluster
built-in audio
um uh sort of the default audio uh
uh capacitor capabilities of it uh were
always
uh easily outdone by middleware
um things like wi's and f mod and and um
and they are they are seemingly
promising far
greater integration of of cool tricks um
and similarly like uh you know the the
ps5
announcements included a breakdown of
audio um and their whole kind of
their home version of something like
ambisonic you know 3d
audio where it's trying to be like they
were promising on
or they were pitching i guess i don't
know how real it would be but on the ps5
things like if you're in a like their
their specific thing they mentioned was
um if you're in a rainstorm and
you know traditionally in games you just
have like a wave file that somebody
has of foley you know someone goes out
into the rain and they literally just
record the rain and there's like a
stereophile or maybe a surround file
of rain and they said you know
next-gen tech will be able to
essentially sample individual rain drops
and have like a million individual
rain events happening which should be
wow exponentially more immersive and the
hardware can handle because the first
thing you think is that's all well and
good it's the same problem that you
mentioned before where
a tech demo where they decide to have a
million individual raindrops
sounds really cool but could you
possibly scale that to a game
of even modest size and they seem to
think so that
you know obviously that's primarily for
sound designers to get all excited about
but there's always
ways that music can potentially benefit
from that level of work as well so
it's exciting we'll see i look forward
to trying to break it i'm i'm just doing
the thing where i google something to
find out if it's been announced yet
bear with me let me tell you what can it
uh at ign i have it
less now because i'm doing a lot less
focused things but i'd often be like
[ __ ] is that andy aide or am i well so
do people know this am i allowed to say
that
what i'm saying austin is you're gonna
love what they're doing with the
controller on player ps5 as well with
the
dual sense stuff there you go haptic
yeah the raindrops thing i've seen some
i've had some demos they're very good
you're gonna that's gonna be some austin
you're gonna have some funny games with
that i think
yeah that sounds to me like i think
mostly under nda
mostly under nda probably i think i've
said as much i just checked their press
release i'm fine
i'm fine all of a sudden it's saying my
internet connection is unstable so
that's
only
that wasn't in the movie was it that
line no they cut it this is a rebellion
isn't it
they also cut the signature shot from
the trailer where the tie fighter comes
up and is staring at her on the platform
and i remember thinking
that's a cool shot but disney make a lot
of stuff for their trailers it's not in
their films
often so that they aren't spoiled and i
like that
i think i think they also did a lot of
reshoots right on that one
probably oh on rogue one for sure they
did yeah yeah
i don't think i mentioned it while we
were recording but everyone uh the clone
wars tv show is very good and that last
season is absolutely incredible and the
last three episodes um
made me cry so go watch that also
and that's it for this week everyone uh
we'll see you guys next week thanks for
joining us